- Back in October, we
did a monster of a show.
It was New Kids on the Block,
Salt-N-Pepa, En Vogue and Rick Astley.
It couldn't have been cooler
to have them all here,
as they got ready to kick
off their Mixtape Tour 2022.
But with all that talent,
all those personalities,
we couldn't contain it in an hour.
This was a lot of people talking, right?
So check out what we
couldn't share until now.
Jordan.
- Yes?
- Who would win in a dance
battle today? I'm just curious.
- I honestly believe we
all have our own moves
that, like, one person-
- Oh, you're a politician.
You're the politician of the group.
(all laughing)
- No, no. I'm serious.
- It's how we've stayed
together for 30 years.
(Kelly laughing)
- No, I'm serious, like-
- [Kelly] Well, you were the
one dancing in the break,
is all I'm saying.
- Oh, yeah. True.
(all laughing)
I just like to dance.
We all like to dance.
- I love that. I do,
I really can't express
how cool that is.
Not a lot of people have
that kind of group around you,
or love around you for your whole life.
Especially being in the limelight.
(audience clapping, cheering)
Like, having that trust?
- A lot of bands don't benefit
from the history they have
for, you know, a lot of
reasons bands break up.
But we have that gift that we were,
we did take some time off.
But now, you know, to
share that with our fans
and embrace it with the history
and a different perspective is, it's like,
such a bonus.
- Especially for people
in the limelight, though,
it's hard to trust people sometimes
and know why they're here, you know?
Like around you. So that's cool.
- We've always kept each other in line.
I mean, that was one thing.
When we got successful at
an early age, it was like,
if somebody pulled up in a Ferrari,
the other guys would be
like, "What's wrong with you?
You grew up taking the subway,
what are you doing
driving a Ferrari?" But-
- And then you ask to drive it?
(all laughing)
- No, no. We really, I mean,
- Then you're like, can
I take it for a spin?
- Where's ours? Yeah.
- We kept it pretty
simple and I think that's,
we attribute that to having
each other, you know?
- Oh that's really cool.
So did y'all also know that you had a gift
for harmony and singing
whenever you were young?
- I didn't even know I could sing.
I think it was about the age of 12,
- I was 13!
- Really?
- Yeah! People think it's
when you're so young!
No. It was 13.
- Exactly.
I was sitting on the
floor looking at cartoons
and my sisters were on the sofa,
and I just started humming the cartoon.
And my sister said, "Terry! You can sing!"
And I was like, "Oh. Okay."
(all laughing)
After that, she had me practicing
after school every day.
- Oh, I love that!
She was like, "you get to work." (laughs)
- You're gonna sing girl.
- I grew up in church singing,
so everyone sang.
- Right.
- So, it wasn't so normal.
Like, everyone around me sang,
that's why I feel like I wasn't,
I didn't really know
until I was, like, 13.
I was like, "Oh, wait, maybe
I can do something with this."
That's cool.
- Mm. Yeah.
- Yeah, what about you, Rhona?
- It's the same way I discovered
harmonizing, was in church.
And singing with the traveling choir,
Soul Children of Chicago, shout out to my
Soul Children alumni.
- It's such a beautiful way
to learn how to sing, too.
'Cause you're not thinking about it,
and you're just, you know,
you're thinking about
something other than yourself.
I love that.
A lot of my friends, that's
how we all grew up singing,
was in church.
But it's kinda tricky though,
'cause everybody's like,
"Oh my gosh, you're such a great singer."
And I'm like, "you should hear the people
I grew up singing with." (laughs)
- Right.
- I grew up singing with some
pretty great singers, so.
Were you always Salt-N-Pepa
or did you have a different,
I heard you had a different name at first.
- Yeah.
- Super Nature.
- Oh my gosh.
(imitates fireworks exploding)
- That wouldn't have worked, right?
- Can you imagine?
- Nah.
- Super Nature is my favorite thing
I've learned about y'all.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's crazy.
- It was so formal.
- Who came up with Super Nature?
- [Both] Hurby.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- And then the fans kinda named us.
Because we, in a rap, said,
"We go together like salt
and pepper" and so it stuck.
And it was like, that works!
- Play that song from them
salt and pepper girls.
- That's what they used to say
on the radio all the time.
- Them salt and pepper girls.
- Oh my gosh, give it up to the fans.
- Yes.
- Well that worked out.
- Give it up to the fans!
- Yes!
(all clapping, cheering)
So you guys all had pretty iconic looks,
everybody up here, back in the day.
But here are some I wanna show.
So, Danny,
this is great.
- Aww.
- Wow.
- Look at you! How cute.
Look, I dressed today to try
and fit in with these. (laughs)
But Danny, are there any
looks that you'd prefer
never to see again?
Just curious.
- [Danny] I mean, I
didn't mind that last one.
This one's okay. We look all right.
- [Kelly] Yeah! I think
you look cool as hell!
I have a ton I wish I'd never done!
(all laughing)
Geez, I'm like what?
That's so awesome! I mean, so much style!
- [Danny] That's when we
were chasing Salt-N-Pepa.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] I love that, you were on top.
(scattered chatter)
- Okay, so what,
- We were wearing our merch.
(Salt-N-Pepa laughing)
Oh, my God! Do you ever,
okay, do you do that though?
Because I sometimes, like,
I have this song called "Love So Soft"
and there's a sweatshirt of mine,
and they made it really soft.
And I just really love
wearing it because it's soft,
but I have to, like,
wear it around my house.
'Cause I'm like,
"what am I gonna show
up with my name on me?"
- Right, right.
- And maybe I will!
- Maybe I will.
- Yeah, why not? Why not?
- Yeah.
- I always wonder 'bout that.
(audience clapping)
I love how soft it is!